we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] pep peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
the patreon
here we are
papa
my 2001.
you got you
we might be drunk you alkies are the
best fans ever should we open some
packages i mean look at this it's like
christmas in here we got so many you
grab one i'll grab another here i'm
reading one here's from oh my lord
we're like barstool
this is from reed
thanks again for giving us some of your
time oh i did these guys podcasts in
nashville it's an honor to have you as a
guest
uh this is great they love okay let's
see what they oh they sent us look at
this right here
holy [ __ ] what is that
oh my god that's going on the wall south
park movie thank you reed going on the
wall appreciate it read candidate thank
you so much and we got a second one we
might have to put it
we have a second but look how good
condition that is my god that is chris
that's pretty good read
man south park
the south park one's going on the wall
for sure oh my god reed
south park bigger longer than uncut
maybe my favorite movie come on give
that a whiff what is it you got a
grinder
oh
man that is insane coffee columbia
guatemala jj's roasters kenya this is
going to win the olympics
mark and sam you guys my favorite comics
i love the show patreon i'm not on the
booze anymore i drink coffee while i
watch the show and i write enjoy gym
this is insane coffee i'm going to make
this tomorrow morning smell that one
jeez this is a wig yeah it's got a dick
drawn on it
ah
it's great i think i like the guatemala
the best but that one's pretty good too
jimbo you're the king
we love you and congrats on not boozing
damn kenny's good too but guatemala is
still holding strong i'm going to buy a
grinder now i've got to get a grind and
brew my friend if you care about coffee
my friend i'm on the account already but
uh i'll get i'll actually buy one
there we go oh
man
this is coming out of uh by the way
gotham studios on uh
what is it 39th west 38th street whoa
one zero zero one eight what is this oh
my lord look at that is that like a what
is this got a patriot a patron a patron
patron i'm drunk huh
i love a rim job
is this bad radio we're doing right now
no it's good tv
bad really yeah we'll post we'll post a
video from this so yeah of course
wow look at that this is a rimmer so
this is part of the bar now you got that
right and look at that it sent nice
glasses
patron is this from patron i think it's
from uh our pal jamie lee jimmy lynn
[ __ ] i'm struggling
look at this [ __ ] jamie look thank you
look at this [ __ ]
jamie you sick [ __ ]
what are you doing
we go way back
i appreciate you this is stupid we have
a full [ __ ] bar now she's a liquor
rep this is her gig
so she really came through man
oh my god
we got like 10 of these
that's got to be 12 glasses and i know
it's in here
thank you jamie bottle openers
oh nice yeah this is just one two three
four five six seven eight that's 12.
ah it's like christmas
oh my god we got bar mats
oh
this is silly well thank you tequila you
guys are smart because we do get
eyeballs in these and you're gonna oh
yeah you're gonna get free ad play what
is that that's patron hats
geez louise i think she thinks we're
opening a actual
nightclub
oh this is too much i feel bad why do
you feel bad look at that shaker come on
do we have this for heights or is she
bringing one
i think dan the beard jew is gonna be
fine
he won't need to bring his supplies
anymore this is legit oh yeah this is
heavy duty
wow jamie you're a mensch
look at this we got shaker this is dude
we have
we got a full bar going on now oh yeah
with a glass inside you see me here oh
my god
this is unreal generous woman really
seems to care
yeah plus the mats
matt's peters
very nice
that's all accused
i know you're jewish but this is what
christmas is like i'm just letting you
know
this is monica we'd have nine more of
these nights
good point whoa
oh whoa look at that
i think you just took it out of there
you go you're good
look at this oh my god this is insane
did you see this matt
this is insane
guys join the patreon right now at
patreon.com we might be drunk get on the
after party i think i just broke this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend